fresh off the injured list and right
back to the mound sunny grey ready to go
sunny gray is the way you got to put it
i mean this guy has got a heart of a
champion uh he's been the really the
pitching leader on this ball club wind
up in the o2
and a miss good start for gray
how about sonny gray in his return to
the mound
he's won three of his last four
decisions has anderson has been able to
keep the ball in the ballpark his last
two outings
see if the reds can cash in on this gift
that the brewers have handed the reds in
the first inning here's the 2-0 and this
ball is jolted to center field hit a ton
back goes taylor gone
nick castillanos belts it out of here to
center field a two run shot his 14th of
the year and the reds lead it two
nothing
that's what i mean by staying the other
way and you just hit it out of dense
interview
but if you pull off that pitch it's a
ground ball to the left side it was down
and it was away
and he stayed right on it really what
i've seen from sonny gray this year is
his ability to pitch left-handers inside
like that where you can locate that
fastball inside boy it opens up the
entire strike zone
how about gray
back to back strikeouts three in a row
overall
3-0 to three and two
on a comeback man
i see i like that better than a
three-pitch strikeout because it really
is a three-pitch strikeout
except you have no margin of error when
you go 3-0 to start off the at-bat
i mean he is pumped up after that too he
pounds his hand into his mitt
tyrone taylor's the banner with two outs
and nobody on a two-nothing reds lead
here's taylor this is it in the air to
center field got a charge to it going
back santel it's gone
tyrone taylor
with a solo shot and the brewers are on
the board
i love the bottom of the order so guard
the seven hitter with a double
in the third now taylor gets the brewers
on the board here in the fifth
they got a fast ball he liked
and wrote it on out of here you see that
two scene was supposed to be inside
because sally's setting up on the inside
corner
sonny gray left it out over the plate on
a 2-1 pitch
one-two pitch swing and a miss he struck
him out with a change up downstairs
it's the fourth strikeout for brett
anderson
and there's one away now here in the
bottom of the fifth inning back-to-back
strikeouts for brett anderson here in
the fifth
chance to strike out the side here in
the bottom half of the fifth
here's the 2-2
and he went he did strike out the side
about that from brett anderson
brewers set up beautifully in the
seventh huge opportunity now for the
brew crew here's the 2-1
arcio with a fly ball hit in the air the
left center field has some carry but not
enough send zell to catch tagging his
vogel back moving to third is jirko and
this game is tied at two there you go
good job by
orlando warship not just plating the run
but getting dirk go to third 2-2 is the
score and now the go-ahead run is
standing at third base with less than
two outs tone will face sogard
2-0 pitch
sogar goes the other way it's down a
base and it gets by aquino all the way
to the wall jerko is in
sogar to second and the brewers lead it
three to two so the brewers with a
three-hit inning
and eric sogart on a 2-0 pitch slices
one down the line and left the brewers
take the lead
three and two the good one
lorenzo the runner at second
the payoff pitch
fastball strike three called
that good one was looking forward just
like we were the change up fastball
right down the middle
pretty play i think he may even have
surprised himself with that play that is
a dandy right here
williams ready with a 1-2
change up swung on and missed out number
one and a beauty over the heart of the
plate down
and another change up and down goes
suarez for out number two
four strikeouts out of the bullpen for
devin williams the one-two
he strikes out mustaches and devin
williams strikes out the side
back to back national league reliever of
the year josh hader
and strike away from the save
the 1-2
fastball swung on and missed and the
brewers win it
oh what work again by the brewers
pitching staff brett anderson followed
by devon williams and then josh hader